Now let's dig in to vote by mail.
This is crazy.
Donald Trump has been continuing to attack
vote by mail while drawing a false distinction,
a vote by mail from absentee ballots while
now telling flitter Floridians that they should
all vote by mail.
So the backstory has been that as the.
Corona virus has raged, voting absentee has
become increasingly important in terms of
safely voting in November.
We have never had a federal election.
Federal presidential election delayed.
We don't plan to do at this time, but we want
to do it safely.
Donald Trump has come out very strongly against
vote by mail.
And we know why.
We looked at a poll on Monday which showed
that among voters planning to vote in person,
two thirds support Trump.
Among voters planning to vote by mail, more
than 70 percent support Joe Biden.
So the data's is clear.
It's crystal clear why Trump would oppose
vote by mail.
Then Trump has sort of either deliberately
or genuinely, you know, we don't know.
He's been confused about vote by mail versus
absentee ballots, even though what we are
talking about this year is expanding absentee
ballot access to whoever wants one, not requiring
certain conditions to be met.
Fear of catching Corona virus should be a
valid reason to vote absentee, often in real
time.
We started to see over the last 72 to 96 hours
contradictions between what Donald Trump is
saying and what his press area press secretary
Kaili McEnany has been saying.
And yesterday, in the midst of a press briefing
during which Kelly was saying one set of things
about the fraudulent nature of vote by mail.
Donald Trump tweets out of nowhere, quote,
Whether you call it vote by mail or absentee
voting, which sort of implies that he's recognizing
it's the same thing, whether you call it vote
by mail or absentee voting in Florida, the
election system is safe and secure, tried
and true what Florida's voting system has
been cleaned up.
We defeated Democrats attempts at change.
So in Florida, I encourage all to request
a ballot and vote by mail.
Magga or Magga, I prefers it to say so.
Now, Trump is saying in Florida specifically,
both vote by mail or absentee, which he's
conceding are the same.
Things are safe in other states where vote
by mail and absentee ballots are also the
same thing.
Except you won't accept it.
Only absentee is safe.
Vote by mail is not safe.
Other states like Nevada who have decided
to expand absentee ballot access to everybody
are really, really bad.
But in Florida, everybody should vote by mail.
This is incoherent that there's just no way
around it.
And Trump was asked about this during yesterday's
press briefing and he came up with some whacked
response about Ron DeSantis is one of the
best governors.
Now, almost everything Trump says, you just
reverse it to find out the truth.
Rhonda Santurce is one of the worst governors
and in fact, has overseen one of the worst
coronavirus responses in the country.
But Trump's explanation was Rodney Sanders
is so great that you can vote by mail safely
in Florida.
So there's speculation about what the real
reasons might be that Donald Trump is saying,
hey, vote by mail in Florida.
It's good there, but not elsewhere.
So a few.
There's kind of two options, a third, which
is pretty ominous.
The first option is very simple.
Trump is concerned with personal hypocrisy.
I know.
How could that possibly be?
But just you know, this is the idea.
Trump knows he voted absentee in Florida.
He recently changed his residence to Florida
and he's being called out about it.
So he wants to make it a state by state issue.
And he's saying, listen, Florida safe.
I voted by mail in Florida.
In Nevada.
It's unsafe.
He attacked Nevada earlier this week.
That's the first possibility.
Second possibility is that there's something
specific about Florida that he's seeing in
polls.
Like I don't believe this idea that it's fine
in Florida because it's safe, but not in Nevada.
What's possible is that there's some polling
data, something about Florida demographically,
maybe, you know, Florida has the fifth oldest
population in the country.
Maybe the 2016 results, combined with the
demographic realities of Florida, make him
think I've got old folks whose votes I need
in Florida.
Let me encourage vote by mail in Florida,
but not in other places.
That's the second possibility.
And always it's because of Trump.
What's best for Trump?
The third possibility.
Which is ominous is does Trump have a reason
to think that Ron DeSantis, this whacked Republican
governor, one of the worst in the country,
does Ron DeSantis have something planned in
Florida where Trump knows that vote by mail
will either not hurt him or will help him
because of funny business that Rhonda Santas
has planned?
Or maybe the Trump campaign has even worked
out with Ron DeSantis.
It's conspiratorial.
There's no doubt it would be treasonous.
It would be immoral.
But remember, in the year 2000, you know,
the Bush Gore contest and how Florida ended
up putting George W. Bush in office effectively
is what took place.
Could Florida do it again?
So what's the solution?
Come on, you guys.
Now, don't let it come down to Florida, make
the results so skewed against Donald Trump
that Florida is actually irrelevant, that
Biden would win with Florida or Biden would
win without Florida.
That's the way to do it.
And by the way, I checked out some of the
pro trump corners of the Internet yesterday
after Trump being against vote by mail for
months.
All of these Trump enclaves are now instantly
falling in lying and saying yes, safe vote
by mail in Florida, vote by mail in Florida,
reelect Trump.
It's fascinating to watch them change their
stance in an instant.
Pretty good sign of a cult when you see that.
Now, here's one idea that I will leave you
with.
Instead of using these terms, vote by mail
or absentee voting, vote by mail and absentee.
Same thing.
Different thing.
Should we just call it vote absentee by mail
like this?
That is that a linguistic solution to a political
problem that might be able to head off some
of the nonsense about one versus the other?
Are they the same or are they not?
I'm voting absentee by mail.
Everybody should vote absentee by mail.
Maybe there's something there.
Maybe I'm very, very wrong.
Let me know what you think.